I asked my brother I said what are your
plans how are you and Kate getting up
there you were not invited on that plane
not invited Prince Harry claims the
royal family excluded him from a flight
to see his grandmother Queen Elizabeth
before she died it is an explosive
Memoir we were promised an autobiography
William is said to be privately seething
and and devastated by his brother and
what he has done in this autobiography
and the King well I think he simply
can't believe what his youngest son has
done
on 60 Minutes the Duke of Sussex goes
into detail about stories in his
upcoming Memoir spare including the
events surrounding his grandmother's
death last September while he was in
London for a charity event it was
announced the queen was placed under
emergency medical watch at Balmoral
Castle in Scotland I asked my brother I
said what are your plans how are you and
Kate getting up there and then
a couple of hours later you know
all of the family members that live
within the Windsor and Ascot area were
jumping on a plane together playing with
12 14 maybe 16 seats you were not
invited on that plane it was not invited
yeah and because Harry says he wasn't
invited he was forced to find his own
last-minute accommodations and as a
result he was too late the queen died
before he was able to say goodbye I
walked into the hall and my aunt was
there to greet me and
she asked me if I wanted to see her I
thought about it for about five seconds
thinking is this a good idea and I was
like you know what you can you can do
this You Need to Say Goodbye
um so I went upstairs took my jacket off
and walked in and just spent some time
with her alone
where was she
was in her bedroom
I was actually I was really happy for
her because she'd finished life she
completed life and
her husband was was waiting for her the
idea of any reconciliation seems almost
unthinkable
what he has
because that's what they are they are
verbal attacks on members of the royal
family and not just any member of the
royal family his father his brother his
mother-in-law his sister-in-law no one
is really spared in spare
a source tells E.T Prince William feels
his brother crossed a line with his
upcoming tell-all our source adds that
the royal family thinks Harry revealing
private details is completely
inappropriate and he's gone about it all
in the wrong way Prince Harry is given a
number of interviews ahead of the
release of his autobiography and he
speaks about wanting to reconcile with
his family he talks about the door being
open but I think the feeling is that
actually he's made sure that door has
been firmly slammed shut
[Music]